hello and welcome to this video playing
cod wound mr. Goldman that--some
Alexander roost em off strong GM a good
blitz player yeah he avoids the most
principled move but I really have my my
knowledge is not sufficient so I have to
have to do this I guess for practical
purposes okay so he opens up the H file
for me is that right hmmm I wonder i
really wonder how this is play i have no
idea it's um see frost and something
that makes sense here is that losing
time maybe it just loses time try to
develop quickly here
I wonder FB should be towards a move
threatening bishop h5 I mean probably
amber Bishop is probably mostly
misplaced down hmm he probably wants to
go 45 so maybe I'm setting this up like
this if he goes g5 I get the e5 square
ok place like this I wants to get any
five but it's not that easy mind I hope
and the Dutch defense is such a weird
opening hard time to figure things out
this is also why i think it's an
interesting opening to play i mean it
has it so it has it has are some
problems of course many many good
players yeah tend to dismiss the dutch
defense but i'm really not that sure the
positions are so I'm non-conventional
and and hard to play that I think the
lack in quality that black maybe suffers
from from time to time is often
compensated by the sheer amount of
practical chances ok anyway what am i
doing now Evie 4f form I don't know
it's a bit lame I know but it didn't
have a clear idea what to do he cannot
go e 5 at the moment when they have a
fourth maybe this is an idea trying to
arrest them a little bit damn a4 a5
okay I was plan anyway in 95 and ideas
to maybe move the night or maybe take
and try to gain time on this the move
like c4 for example like it takes with
the pawn that's very interesting I wants
to play Knightly form possibly f4 hmm
okay mm f4
hmm I have no idea I don't understand
this position notnot bit yeah fe for ya
yeah it was kind of cleared
hey I always have problems against this
age six and g5 thing simply because i
don't i don't have a recipe at never
looked looked at this line and I just I
just don't get good positions this is
just not any good position looks
entirely on ammonius now it's many good
moves on g4 is good
and i probe the other things to spell
yeah g one that's a great square and
okay but i can go d 5 in this position
he's not attacking this at the mode i
think i'm happy that i can get in d5 him
and why why exactly can I not take f 40
well I'm here b3 wasn't a move I was
dreaming about but what can you do hmm
take F for the end does g4 yeah this is
the thing okay I put it here I 94 i
still have quincy to time working and
that's probably bad for white anyway
hmm how bad is this if I get in Bishop's
III 92 this is not so bad actually I
still sg4 en this position and
threatening before though show page 3 is
surprising I can maybe take what okay i
just got 97 coming coming up
anyway I just have to play quickly and
hope for the best it's objectively
losing anyway probably come on now
you're playing this miracle moosie on me
Bishop chinks chinks chinks I don't know
I be sure as his he cannot take on the
tool that's made on the aid that's very
lucky and he doesn't have rookie h1
check even Wow I'm completely winning
Jack oh my good oh my goodness the thing
is I have no time still check how to 13
seconds Queenie to next I can take f2a
next Jeff
check check check check check I cannot
go Ruby one chat fortunately bra offer
in no no check that's no reason to draw
his neck I'm winning truly worth its own
time hey I was just winning him I think
unless he had a perpetual that I didn't
understand that it's possible it while
he completely killed me and then he
blundered it all the way now I was
completely killed in this game I really
had absolutely no idea what to do in
this position yeah I think there is a c4
move which which leads to yeah amazing
complications after Bishop g7 or Luke
age 7 but I have really have no idea
what's going on down maybe I should
still do it oh I should look it up this
is I mean this is not III is not
terribly bad it was playback aspera for
example in some games but yeah that
cannot be though the way to get
something against the Dutch Jim I mean I
just went for normal kind of normal
development but it just didn't it just
didn't feel right not sure maybe I'm not
in terrible shape but it got worse very
quickly yeah this is this most probably
not a good idea he takes him after that
he has a very nice position the night
can come to you for both my bishops look
bad this is also why I went see form i
was i was aware that this is probably
very risky but didn't want to sit there
with that bishop
this is a very bad position I'm just
lost here objectively I guess oops that
was a bit quicker I have to do this but
the endless wants to go g4 and gives me
like a win okay dad can you say I just
lost yeah as I said he be totally killed
me but he missed some ways to end the
game I mean g4 ends the game probably
high because of this Wow now I was
completely busted at the way it window
also was excellent for him provoking b3
was nice and ok well the engine now says
it's equal again but I still felt I'm in
trouble with the long diagonal giant
here it's crazy rook takes the one is a
clear advantage for white I don't know
why we're before probably before we take
see one I wanted to do this to counter
on the long diagonal but this is it
seems excellent engine says I'm winning
him amazing Plus 1.3 g always before him
and it wants to play this now I
understand this night it has no squares
him remarkable now I was I was more in
defensive mode and thought I should
oppose on the diagonal is also better
for what amazing rook see one yeah I
mean it was clear to me that he could
have done something better but I wasn't
sure you know Angie form and now I can
actually take I had to have to be honest
I just believed him here
and didn't think about this move too
long this is this and subha engines
gives equal though with this with this
moves and T I can yep try to perpetual
myself okay i just went here and now I'm
lost again krug h1 this also wins he
just has to instead of this give the
check first yeah and now I'm completely
busted look you one they can take do you
want a key FOIA okay it's it's a total
loss he simply he simply forgot about
the maid he wanted to play rook t2 here
and has made only eight I mean this is
just immensely lucky yeah then read
through gauge one just killing the rook
yeah I'm this is was just goes plain
playing really really badly and then he
handed me the point with this those two
blunders okay men of course I had no
time whatsoever so maybe can't think I
am pretty much can kept things kind of
together okay to know it's amazing but
okay oops check I was happy to play play
Mosby seven now is winning but this
chance of winning I guess yeah you can
still I actually could have done that
check because of Queenie to I didn't see
that check but yeah so I yeah right here
offers a draw it and I'm just Winningham
no poo it's a kind of kind of game where
you're vain hope you you have a lucky
Dame okay thanks for watching